yeah I'm from New Orleans Louisiana
um I came out here when I was 17 no I
came out here by myself ah no I only had
my mom my real father passed away when I
was six years old um he passed away from
full-blown AIDS cuz he was he he stopped
using drugs but he went from one
addiction to another and he was having a
lot of unprotected sex with different
it's easier he got it from having
unprotected sex or somebody that I can't
that worked in the program with him had
tattoo my grandmother's name and the
needle could have been yes so it
couldn't either being from having
unprotected sex or a dirty needle
and so you came to LA at 17 yeah it had
his good days and his bad days but my
mom was a single mom she did the best
she could then she had a boyfriend right
and her boyfriend were less than me for
like 30 years then he raped me I was
like 11 years old when I happy so then
my mom thank God my mom caught him but
instead of like she was like she she
believed me
you know most women when they're kids
give me when their kids come telling oh
I'm being molested
they believed they believed the bad guy
over their own children not my mom my
mom didn't do that my mom was chased him
out the house down the stairs with a
big-ass knife like that my neighbor our
neighbors I lived across rumors had to
stop her because she was gonna kill him
I had a couple of friends out here like
it south sexually it was Freddie shotgun
I was pretty cool
I started [ __ ] with like I started
doing like I was already [ __ ] with
drugs I was doing like powder and
ecstasy pills then I start [ __ ] with
crystal meth now here when I first got
out and ecstasy pills I was doing that
[ __ ] back home but when I came out here
I started [ __ ] away crystal yeah
so you do it on the street how long I've
been living on the street since my 18th
birthday on and off yeah um I got
friends that got s Saros
but most of the time I do sleep in a
tent yeah depends on how I feel I
prostitute most of the party yeah and I
sell drugs every every blue moon burned
I'm scared but I'm scared to get a
[ __ ] direct sales case I already got
a felony on my record I don't need no
more trouble um this dude put his hands
on me and I stopped I stopped there I
was this close to hitting him in his
heart so then Sean charged me for it um
first-degree attempted murder but then I
had a good lawyer
so they dropped it down from that to
assault with a deadly weapon with great
bodily injury
I know yeah yeah
24 yet to see an experienced I wouldn't
believe it or not you ever heard of
somebody caught the Grim Sleeper yeah I
bet I'd David
um he pick up street workers and he
shoots him and hey that's his MO it's
only me and one other lady that actually
survived that vehicle to the to he black
he black and only reason they call him
the Grim Sleeper was because he stopped
for like 14 years before he started
before he started again and so what
saved me was I had a locket right but I
had I had a picture of my niece in my
lucky right and he was like give me one
reason why I shouldn't kill you you
piece of trash somebody look let me show
you something and I opened my lock it up
and I'm like you see her I'm like that's
my daughter and he was like your bear
thank god that's the only reason I ain't
gonna kill you yep and he let me out the
car he didn't do nothing he let me out
the [ __ ] car well it is very rare
don't know now is that was God protect
no that was God protecting me no I don't
believe in like I believe in blessings
of curses it wasn't my time it was like
it's been so many times where I met deaf
faced and facing I'm still here I told
him that that was my niece I told him
that so I sound good God yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I know so it depends on how how
the traffic is you know that PI like no
less than like 150 but it all depends
it depends what they want except angle
that's one I've been so I got no I got
raped and sodomized by a cop out here
yeah yeah so I'm like anybody that goes
near that I'm a fight no I'm a fight
yeah no I've stopped doing them I
stopped doing meth when I thought that
was pregnant my oldest son when I was 19
um crack I drink alcohol I smoke weed
and I do hair on every I don't shoot up
by yeah I chase the dragon and I snorted
um it'd be pink but sometimes if it
ain't going right I say [ __ ] it I'll
smoke me some weed drink me little bit
alcohol eat and go mice to sleep yeah
yeah it is yeah it isn't Russian I know
but I'm very intelligent you guys my
friends like I watch like Animal Planet
hey stretch I know stuff like that and I
got a good member I got like perfect
Greek home yeah yeah but I love it
people think I my own soul because the
way up the way I talk about nice stuff a
lot of people ask me have I been
accomplished no no I talked out a night
I just watched educational [ __ ] still a
reality [ __ ] this is reality show
right here real life you feel me
[ __ ] all that love and hip-hop sitting
on this is this is in full life and
living color right there no Photoshop no
nothing no paycheck no nothing just
everyday life
yes yep right raw super all rode in a
[ __ ] full rare steak I wanted
to be a doctor growing up by foot
baguette I got a found out that felony
they're not gonna let me work in a
hospital so what I want to do is be a
motivational speaker to at-risk youth to
like the gang bit yeah and tell them
look I'm gonna leave a testimonial on it
you think gangbanging selling dope all
this [ __ ] you think using drugs here
near as cool nah bro it ain't cool it
ain't cool ain't all fun all that
glittering go so I think that's what I
really want to do be motivational speed
of address you yes
no problem